hello and welcome to the show my name is
hans kim
um
and i'm just having a good time right
now playing a little katan
thought i'd tune you into the fun just
did a little show at a little
housing authority a little suburban
complex
and it was a fun time
i'm having a blast
um
so yeah i mean i'm just i'm just
chilling
in the cut
having a good time
um
joe rogan was recently i was listening
to his podcast with greg fitzsimmons he
was talking about how he wrote
and how the process it goes and goes
and it's a fun time
uh
and you know just excited to hear about
it glad that it's happening
comedy that is
um
so if you don't know how to play
there's a little video
oh my gosh
you're gonna steal from me
everyone's stealing from me
it's like we're all pretty close you can
steal from black too
uh okay then it's still for me
uh
community rules
this is how you play katan
an online alternative to settlers of
catan
the objective of the game is to reach 10
victory points before the other players
points may be gained through building
settlements upgrading to cities
buying development cards or achieving
the longest road
what's up
so
the way i write is i write 2 000 words
every day
into my computer
and then whenever something comes up in
my head i write that too
so a little bit of both
at the start of the game each player
places two settlements and two roads
settlements may be placed at the
intersections of the tiles like these
highlighted spots
and they cannot be placed next to any
other settlement
as you can see there are different
resource tiles and numbers on them
when the game starts each player
receives the resources that their second
settlement was placed on as a starting
hand
these can be wood brick
sheep
tweet or ore
during the game each player begins their
turn by rolling the dice
regardless of who rolls the dice if you
have a city or settlement touching the
tile with the matching number that was
rolled you collect resources from the
bank
however however if a seven is rolled no
one gets resources since there's no tile
with the number seven on it instead each
player will check their hands to see if
they have seven or fewer resources in
their hands
if they have eight or more they'll have
to discard half of them back to the bank
the player the player who rolls a seven
will then need to move the robber to
another tile and is able to steal one
random resource from one of the players
with a settlement or city attached to
that tile
that tile that has the robber won't
produce any resources until the robbers
moved again
if you were lucky enough to escape the
robber and keep your resources on your
turn you may now choose to build roads
settlements upgrade upgrade your
settlements to cities
buy development cards
play a development card
or trade with other players in any order
you prefer
colonist.io helps you remember each
building cost as they are shown while
hovering over each of the options at the
bottom of the screen
roads help you expand to new places to
build settlements and require one wood
and one brick
these are placed on the edges of the
towels and must be connected to your own
existing
must be built away from other
settlements and must be connected by
your own roads they require one wood
brick sheep sheep
and wheat
cities will replace one of your existing
settlements and are now worth two
victory points as well as producing two
resources whenever its numbers are
rolled
these can be built with two wheat and
three ore developments velma cards have
a variety of surprises and uses
okay anyways
now we're back to the catan
we're having a good time we're chilling
hello hans i'm here to tell a joke
without care worry about setting or who
is listening dave
here's the face cam so my name is hans
kim this is what my eyes look like
hey what's up
um
i think that it's funny that uh
you know in the suburbs
they uh it's a food desert so it's hard
to
survive there unless you have a car and
it's like unless you have a car it's not
built really for human beings it was
just weird because we are human beings
and instead we design our cities for
the objects
and stuff
that are not us which is an interesting
move
[Music]
but
yeah i mean
i'm having a good game i kind of wish i
could go here i kind of wish i could go
here
then i could get a sheep
and i wouldn't have to
pay for it with two wood i really don't
know what i'm gonna do now with my life
oh no
let's see if anyone wants to help me
be a man
but even if i get this it's not gonna
help
what i could do
is i could
buy
the most expensive development card ever
[Music]
or
i could do something else i could invest
in the future
i could get two
of these [ __ ]
and hope that a seven gets rolled and i
don't get picked
that's what i'm gonna do
hallelujah i don't think there's many
options this on three dots
you know this is probably gonna be
picked he has seven cards already
i could go up here i could go down here
and there's really not much i can do so
i'm just gonna build a city
and have a good time doing it
so i just did a show and a little
homeowners association that sucks
because the six so valuable
and the robbers on top of it
oh
what are you gonna do well such as life
you know the thing that sucks about
katana is if you're losing you're just
losing for a while
and there's not really too much you can
do about it
it's a very slow paced game look it's
the clear water bottle
um this guy's just building a bunch of
roads he only has three points the best
he could do is red could take away the
two points that blue has with the
longest road
um
anyways
so i'm having a good time um
7
yes please move the robler
he put it on the 3
i'm hoping that was
not a stupid move um
because he's not doing very well
so it doesn't make sense oh and then he
moved it to blue who is winning right
now with eight points
in the longest road
um
[Music]
okay that was a little abrupt no one
wants to trade with me
now i can build a city as long as i
don't get seven which i shouldn't
because i'm not winning
i've got too many cards now
to too many cards
which is a good problem to have
yep but just living life having a good
time
what should i talk about there's always
something to talk about um
ever thought about fighting for money no
because i don't want to fight for money
that seems hard
and sweat inducing
i could build two roads one two three
four five six and the record is five
but uh yeah i think
wood and brick are more valuable to me
than wheat so i'm just gonna get rid of
this
[ __ ]
build a
city and then build two roads
somewhere
like that i mean i could build here
i'm gonna try to go for the lg the
longest road i think i can do it
i think i can
i gotta believe in myself
um but yeah i mean
just playing katana a lot so i was like
hey why don't i just turn this into
something productive and then i started
recording it
and now it's sort of like work so
you know this is
me writing i'm trying to come up with
bits by
stuttering into the camera and
not really
having a high quality
thing that i'm doing
um but
yeah i mean maybe i could oh [ __ ] blue's
gonna connect that road
hopefully black can [ __ ] him up
uh but that's a long ass road that's
seven
eight nine ten one two three four five
six
i only have six
damn i could have cut him off
one two now i can't cut him off
um
it might not be feasible for me to get
longest road
which would
suck because i just built these two
roads for nothing then
i could just build here
might as well right
i wish black would build two roads here
keep him at seven
but he's buying a rock which is not
needed for a road
um
damn so many sevens
i might need to build
a settlement here
i'm getting so many fours
where's the brick part right here i
can't get it
um you know i can be a comedian and a
game streamer
i think fighting is a
kind of a risky career move
i don't know if i would do it
oh my god he stole from me
oh rosh johans if you continue to be
belligerent
you are so delusional
this doesn't
work the game is distracting you from
work
um i mean what is work you have to be
miserable to work is that the only way
that uh you know what work is and also
how would you know i also question your
authority to tell me what to do
i think that you want to
tell someone what to do and boss them
around
and then you find
someone where you can do that whether
it's needed or not
so i question your authority and i
besmirch your name and i
say that
you are
um annoying
and uh why would
tony and redband say if they could see
you right now
this guy's just trying to be that
voice of
puritanical
you know judeo-christian insecurity and
um
like
guilt
because that's what is inside of his
head is like
guilt and overwhelming shame of
whatever so
you know it's interesting that he's like
that and sad that he is like that as
well
the sentence versus muhammad prediction
i know vincente lukey below muhammad i
don't know that well
so i guess i'm going for vincente lucky
um
[Music]
i mean you say that you're helping me
with tough love but i think you just
like to
um do tough love whether it's useful or
not so
i'm i'm just gonna ignore you and
anything that you do
um
and i think that the
fact that that's your first go-to
is like your
own sickness that you have to berate
people and i think that's sad
i feel bad for you
i could have gotten a rock
um
what's the brand of your clear assuming
prescription glasses i have no idea i
think it's negative 1.25 to 1.25
negative 1.25 to negative 1.5
i'm not too clear
um
like unlike my glasses i don't know i'm
not clear
um
you know what's funny is like we should
all motivate ourselves to be better
people every day
and
the way that i do it is that i
try to um
understand and
be one with humanity in society and that
we should um
be
more loving to people because people are
like what we are
and uh
we are beautiful beautiful things in the
world
look at us look how beautiful we are
beautiful
um
what's the
bra okay
um the us military i respect oh [ __ ]
okay
oh yeah i can do that
um let me take take take
who put the robber on me i was too
distracted
getting yelled at by random people
uh let's take from blue obviously
and then let's build a settlement
call it a day
even if i connect this is it even
feasible to get 12 roads 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12. i can only tie or i can beat
him
if i build
one two three four five roads at once
oh no
i don't know if i can do it
but um
yeah i'm having a good time
um
they played that old cadbury egg
commercial again this year
no the tan is a joke oh my god
this always happens to me why me
why why god why
why are you doing this to me well this
gives me another chance to [ __ ] with
blue
i'll put it here that's six dots frame
the six six
four six
okay this is good enough
obviously blue
please give me something useful
um
let's get one of these
let's build a road
for no reason i mean what else have i
got to do
so
[Music]
i got eight he's got eleven one two
three four one two
i really really can't do much if he
builds another road
anyways
oh my gosh
no he took my rock
i paid two wood for that
and he almost has the largest army
which is a thing
oh no he's gonna take from me again
i took from another person
oh no that was black taken from blue
black and blue
um
so trying to give you a job because he
was under fire needed an asian fall guy
yeah
i admit that
i mean for a token asian guy
i've done pretty good for myself
i would challenge any token asian guy
to line up
and see
who's the better one you know
like just because that's what i am
doesn't mean it's a bad thing
or that it can't be done well
um but
i i'm having fun doing it
it's a blast
i'm gonna ask them to help me get
longest road
i need
four of these
oh [ __ ]
this is
that guy is the guy that's winning
seven yourself [ __ ]
um
yeah i mean uh he that's the reason why
he booked me is because you
there's an asian thing that happened and
i was asian and then what happened
because of that
is that i became
i showed them what i could do or what i
do and then they
liked it or didn't like it and mostly
they liked it and then
i did a lot of things with it so you
know just because that's how it happened
doesn't mean
it's a good thing or a bad thing
what the [ __ ] why are they stealing from
me
or black i guess
you know blue is winning right
and if he has a knight we're all [ __ ]
i mean you could have blocked this rock
just play your knight if you have it
don't be a dick
okay well now i can't get longest road
damn that's a long ass road
so jealous of this guy
he has two
oh my god these people are [ __ ] they
didn't block the guy with the most
number of points they blocked the guy
with
who were losing
slightly ahead of them
and then he got three rocks and was able
to build a city
what am i gonna do
um red ben is great he's very funny i
think he's very underrated i think
people don't understand how funny he is
and i love it i love red band
[Music]
and
i think it's
great to be around
what is even the point we're all going
to lose anyways
life is meaningless we are all but dust
oh my god that robber is so annoying
i should blame red
for this horrible nightmare
he has no idea how to play
he's just trying to build a nice little
beautiful little image and he's not
trying to get 10 points
and defeat others from
prevent them from getting 10 points
oh my god he has 11 cards there's
definitely some way he can
manage to build something
oh my gosh what a bunch of morons
two three four whoa a lot of sixes a lot
of fives
fives benefit black and orange that's me
sixes benefit me
oh my god
these [ __ ] idiots how many times do
they block me they blocked me seven
times
then they took
three from me
maybe block i don't want to say that
maybe block the guy that's winning next
time you [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you want a chance to win
and here we go another game of katan is
underway
we got a 12 spot right here this is a
road making spot this is where you go to
make all the roads
and here this is 11 slightly less
dots but
a diversity of dots this is
9 12 right here or 11 no 12 right here
this is a very valuable spot and in fact
i will choose it as my own
huzzah
i choose the
because this is 12
this is 12.
this is 11.
yeah dog
let's go [ __ ]
i got the 6 5 dot and 4 dot
which is going to be good for making
cities yeah baby making cities
uh this is a game called katan
uh
ryan redman's real name is brian reichel
um
so
the funny thing is
that um
there's a lot of
a lot of things going on
people nowadays are more narcissistic
and less willing to look silly they're
all into primping and propping
themselves up and being like
look at me i'm not a silly man i'm a
very serious fella
do not try to question me i know a lot
of things at all at the same time
and uh people in the 70s were just like
yeah i'm just kind of a [ __ ] up i'm sort
of a loser and whatever
i guess uh there's some like you know
meth heads and uh drunk skater boys but
i feel like the tech bros and the uh you
know texas's
texases
i'm gonna write that down
um but they're just like
they're just so full of themselves it's
nauseating they're just like i have to
be the best person they don't just have
to be like a little part of a larger
thing they have to be the best
all-around person
tech bros and texas
okay texas is
brilliant
bravo
oh look he picked this shittier spot
it doesn't even matter looking at the
board right now because it's going to be
so different what i need is brick and
sheep the brick and sheep are here
so i need this
other otherwise i'm going to have to
forego one or the other
um i could forego the sheep right here
if we go the sheep somewhere here
or i could
forgo the brick right here brick right
here forgot the brick right here
uh etc etc
i have a new comedy show coming out it's
called guns and puns stay tuned for guns
and puns it's a texas themed show where
we use the threat of physical violence
and the threat of intellectual
mockery
to really
give the audience a
give the audience a hoot and hollering
scared scary time
um
the system works the only thing lacking
is your loyalty it's a little meme that
i made like that's the kind of message
that i get from motivational speakers
it's like man you just have to work hard
man you don't even have to think
you don't need to have to like make sure
your work is going to a good place
you're thinking about the overall
picture you just have to put your head
down and do your small little part
really well because we have a system
that rewards effort and
uh contribution and not one that doesn't
um so why wouldn't you contribute
but yeah i mean what if the system is
corrupt and
uh it
tricks you into working hard for no
reason
or if it's just not a very good system
and you don't want to waste your life
contributing to it
and
the only way that you should contribute
like you should you're like don't think
about the way society is going just
um do
uh the best
and contribute to it the most even
though it hasn't done the bare minimum
to require or to engender that kind of
uh
hope or motivation it's like just come
on give us your all even though we
provide you with no sort of meaning or
purpose or vision for the future just
contribute to our grand project even
though we don't know where it's going or
what it's for
like if you want me to
put my life's effort into something you
better
know
what it's for at least
the very minimum
that'd be nice
if we had like a general idea
of what we were doing
um you know with katan the point the
port the position on the board it isn't
just about
the number of dots it's also
geographically like where you want to go
and what you want to do with it
you got that tree port
i was going to get that you get five
seven dots here
and then go up here
i could get the brick the whatever port
i would love brick i don't have any
brick right now
the only way i can get brick is here
get the brick port and make sheep out of
brick
which i heard is a very difficult thing
to do
um or i could do eight dots here
six dots here
but with the brick port
this is a rock port i already have a
rock port coming up do i really need
another brick port
the good thing is that i would [ __ ] this
guy over
five
this is a wood port
that would [ __ ] this one up
i could build here eight dots
i wish i had that wood port but i could
get this one
um
so what i think i'm gonna do
i can get the brick port here and then
build up
um over here
and try to get this or something
then i get one more six eight
um so that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna forgo the sheep
seven
five
eight
to get eight dots here and i get sheep
uh
six dots
i like that eight dot
and the one wheat i like this
and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go towards
this is not a very valuable spot this is
a slightly more valuable spot five seven
points
this is five points
imma go down here
hell yeah brother
hell yeah brother man
i ain't got no bricks
i just need one more wheat and i can
build a city oh [ __ ] someone ruled a
seven
uh so here's a little little query for
you guys have you tried uh being mean to
homeless people until they go away why
is that a strategy
uh you know like why don't why don't we
try doing that a little bit
who wants one come on little piggies i
know you want to build a road
i know you need it you little [ __ ]
sheep for wheat sure doggy
and then i build 9 12 dots right here as
opposed to the 8 dot
i'm on the map
accruing those points [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] not another seven
anyways
omg it's hans kim says yonder wizard
what's up yonder good to see you hope
you're doing well brother brother man
uh
[ __ ] he took my sheep that's my sheep
that's my sheep [ __ ] why you taking my
sheep [ __ ]
oh yes i'm getting so mad i'm so mad all
the time i need to get rid of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass robber
thank you
you can steal anything you want as long
as you move this [ __ ]
nice he didn't take me out
uh this game is job typical millennial
yeah what what's your job you think jobs
have to be what boomers tell you what a
job is that's so silly
you're like oh he's trying to have fun
well we all know life is supposed to be
miserable
what are you trying to have fun for you
[ __ ] why don't you try to be miserable
like me i love being miserable i'm so
good at it and if we all lived in a
world where we were miserable i would
win
yeah no one wants to do that bro
no one wants to be miserable for a job
sorry that i'm trying to have a better
job than you
uh
i hate benny back depending on the
situation you never know when the
homeless person is carrying a shank of
some
kung kind
um yeah you don't want to get shanked by
a homeless person but um
the thing is like homeless people should
be prevented from becoming homeless by
having affordable housing
and uh
a good life and
a lot of good stuff
um and you know there's ways to avoid
creating homeless people
uh one of them is to not be such [ __ ]
to them
um
and like if there was an animal that was
out on the road uh it'd be like oh my
god a dog let's take it in
and we should do the same thing for
people we should just give people homes
and food because
we live love them
and uh
yeah then uh
then they'll be awesome awesome people
um
and then the world would be a better
place and it won't feel shitty
um
so where does gen x come in to play in
this world of boomers and millennials
gen x is like
the guy from ferris bueller's day off
the long-faced cameron guy
gen x affordable housing comes from not
letting central banks run everything
central banking
i mean i think that might be a problem i
think
a bigger problem might be corporate
interest and wealth inequality in people
who are rich just hoarding all the
wealth and just this mentality of
you know keeping it all to themselves
um
and then we should uh you know have a
system where people try to do the most
good for society and not just make the
most money because it turns out those
two things are not always the same thing
um you know benny mack came into this
chat just telling me reprimanding me
telling me what to do and then he says
it's
he doesn't like it well you know what
it's like you came in with the wrong
attitude buddy
um maybe you should lighten up uh have a
good time relax
um
enjoy life a little bit instead of just
being critical and angry you know
there's a lot more to life than judging
everyone and everything for any reason
at all
and um
[Music]
yeah i mean benny mack is just
this uh very interesting thing
um
give me a sheep
two sheep for one brick sure
okay
and now let's build yonder
over yonder
yonder wizard
central bank aka the federal reserve
very
gen x equals invisible generation
they're just sort of like oh here you go
oh okay we'll go over here we'll destroy
this rain forest you told us to okay
we'll do this okay sorry guys oh sorry
they're like canadians gen x are like
the canadians of the generations what
advice would you give someone with bad
sad cause doing a comedy is like the
polar opposite of it
sad is a seasonal affective disorder or
small asian dick
if you have a small asian dick i would
recommend that you dangle things from
your [ __ ] and try to get it longer
if you have seasonal affective disorder
i would say
um
you know find a better season go to
somewhere and find a better season of
somewhere to be
um
[Music]
i think that uh you know
finding hobbies like humans if you're
controlled by the weather and the
seasons then there isn't enough meaning
and purpose to your life you should be
able to find something deeper
and more significant than the weather to
make you feel better about yourself
and i believe in you you can do it let's
do it
um i need brick
i need brick man
does anyone have brick
i really like some brick
i could get it on my own
but you know what are you gonna do
i just need to ask you guys for some
break man
it's not really like some brick
oh you don't have it [ __ ] you then
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
they don't like the us early 90s
culture was about condemning
a consumer culture
uh
that's why kurt is dead
why aren't your eyes open how snap they
are
okay
stealing from may
blue's got four points too
uh yeah i mean 90s were a very shallow
culture their music doesn't really live
on and that's sort of like where we're
at i mean 2000s what was it like [ __ ]
whatever not that significant music
you know like
what what's the deal with the 90s it's
all [ __ ] and stuff
nice
it all worked out now all my spots are
clear
and it will be for the next two turns at
least
this is colonist.io a katan remake dude
what the [ __ ]
why is my number not being rolled
oh my god another seven this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] man this sucks
but um
yeah i mean
the thing is that uh we need to have a
better culture
and we don't and we need to not be like
the 90s we got gotta avoid that and we
don't
oh my god they stole from me so many
times
these jealous little [ __ ]
come on six what the [ __ ]
fives fours so many of these [ __ ]
numbers
oh my god oh my god
this is so bad
um
if
a wizard gave you one wish what would it
be
my one wish would be that
everyone would
be
taken out of the profit motive and then
motivated by
something better and more awesome
uh called the love of humanity
and we could stop outsourcing our
empathy and love to an invisible man in
the sky and not giving any love to our
fellow man and human beings
um
we're wasting all this love and energy
to this
random ass bearded dude and maybe we
should be using that love for something
deeper and better
better thing to love
um but uh i know a lot of bands that you
haven't heard anything they got bigger
together oh [ __ ] mario mother
oh my god what the [ __ ] man
all these [ __ ] fours and fives
some [ __ ]
six i love sixes
i need to be
in
another area
i can buy a development card like this
even though it's expensive
one rock for one sheep no thank you
because i'm helping out this guy who's
my closest enemy
hans you have naturally skeptical
eyebrows thanks man one of them is
higher than the other
but um
yeah i mean my numbers haven't been
really getting rolled a lot
and you know sometimes i look at the
dice
die distribution and it's not very even
so it's just interesting how life is out
to get me
come on baby
daddy needs a new pony
six is yeah baby i love sixes
i would rather i have another thing but
that's fine
hopefully it doesn't have a monopoly
because i'll get [ __ ] if he has a
monopoly card
come on [ __ ]
you done [ __ ]
what is life even
i got two sheep
two sheepies
and then buy
two debbie cards
then with this one
i don't even know what i can do
why don't i just get a brick huh why
don't you just get a [ __ ] brick dude
huh
six is again yeah baby we're rolling and
trolling
oh that time it's so hurtful
uh hey hans you know how to do taxes
yeah you just fill in the [ __ ] sheet
you know in other countries taxes are
way easier to do they make it difficult
in america because you people let them
because you're [ __ ] weak and you let
them walk all over you
you have no control over your own
government they prey upon you
and yet you do the most hem-hawing about
good government control and [ __ ]
it's like do something about it then
jesus
all you do is have your stupid guns
it's not enough man you gotta do more
than that
um
[Music]
let me take from blue
what does everyone have too much of
i could get more devi cards
in fact that's what i'm gonna do
oh yeah baby
fours and fives
so unfair baby
two seven one six one four red is not a
threat apparently
thankfully
[Music]
hallelujah i can buy
dev cards for market price
there's a lack of wood and lack of wheat
um what do i wanna do
okay what i want to do
is i wanna play my night
no way
i wanna buy dev cards
one two
oh my god and then i'm gonna play a
knight obviously
and i'm gonna [ __ ] over blue or black
i'll [ __ ] over black
because it's so easy no i don't want to
[ __ ] over black because he has two death
cards
i'll [ __ ] over blue
blue
[Music]
is what i call my love
for you
and then i can't use another dev card so
whatevs
red
i need to use my monopoly card
this is what it does
because sometimes i keep it and i never
use it and then i never use it
and then i never used it
taxation is extortion well so is
uh company
paying you less than what you deserve
um you know extortion like you pay for
the roads
and the uh clean air and water and
environmental protection
just ask dave smith lol
why do you love this game so much also
you people your freedom of speech
triggers me
uh i love this game so much because it's
simple it's easy it's fun it's just
i don't know
it's strategy it's interesting
it's a good pace
people have a good time playing it
yeah it's a good game
it's a good game
do i want to wait no i don't
okay
i could ask for wood or i could ask for
weight
okay buddy
um you deserve what you agreed to be
paid you want to get paid more than
negotiate that [ __ ] and if you deserve
to get taxed based on what country
you're in if you don't want to get taxed
move to a different country
move to a country without taxes oh wait
there is no country without taxes
because that's the only way countries
work
but i mean you don't want to pay too
many taxes and that's where democracy
and voting comes in
which i'm a huge fan of
um
sheep and wheat
there's a lack of sheep and there's a
knock of wheat
should i ask for it or should i just
move this [ __ ]
i'm just gonna move this [ __ ]
over to
black
this time
why not
but eh getting up
um
i want to build a thing
okay
one minute please
hello
and welcome
um my name is hans kim
i'm having a good time
um so
the thing is like
i
am just chilling and
i kind of want to
talk about something interesting so if
you have anything that you want to talk
about please let me know
um
i uh
he's talking to a babe you can tell by
how excited he looks damn i look excited
then become irreplaceable or start your
own biz andrew well you know not
everyone can just start their own
business
you know we can't just have a society
where everyone has a business
what we need to do is protect the people
when they're coming up with their
business and they're working low minimum
wage jobs and provide them with basic
food and shelter and human requirements
so that they can start their business
and not so they can worry about their
basic human animal needs
uh
around this mob analogy i'm at all
so the thing is that i think that um
you know the basic concepts of
uh
capitalism are built around shady
foundations of having to defend slavery
and genocide of native americans
and so they're they're just giving an
economic scientific reason for why they
were like it's okay to murder
indians and enslave black people
and go to india and rape their country
for resources and
ignore them while they starve to death
it's okay to do these things
and uh you know that's what the whole
thing was built upon
that's the beginnings of it and it was
just there's just so much gunk and [ __ ]
in there that's just
designed to okay tragedies and
atrocities
um
[Music]
and i think like a more nuanced
interesting version
of
the idea of humanity should be
put forward and i think that
we could really use
a better system
and
i know just the guy to do it his name is
mel zedong
everyone come with me to meet belle
zedong
the greatest hero in the land he's got
lots of food and
cans
um
yeah i mean
obviously
there's a lot of questions on who
we should be worshiping and why
and what for and all that
but uh you know i i just think tell us
what your favorite type of art or
artistic movement is probably this
artistic movement
wow i don't think i've looked more
artist autistic
africans leave their own people and sold
them to us
yeah but what you did was even worse
than african selling
africans to white people
south america got like 50 times more
slaves than north america
okay yeah and then
they uh and who did that the spanish
um
i mean it's like kind of weird
it's kind of well you guys say it's
weird to do these things like you want
to go back to the past do you know
anything about phrenology
and uh you know the slave trade the
people that were doing the slave trade
said it was okay to do this thing that's
what the [ __ ]
uh
[Music]
so the [ __ ]
uh south capitalism is based on
[Music]
uh how much do you get paid opening for
joe daddy a lot of money show me my
signature on the social contract who
says it you're being born this gift is a
this life is a gift and you're just like
i don't want to contribute all i want to
do is take from this world and have a
pleasurable experience do something with
your experience give back
um
yeah and then this argument that uh oh
it's not bad what we did look what they
did they did something bad too what you
did was way worse it was way worse to
have chattel slavery and use people like
objects and breed them and [ __ ]
uh you know do horrible things to them
it's not a nice thing that you guys did
and it
uh it's interesting that you don't want
to admit it so much it's just look at
other people
all these evils were around before
capitalism existed yeah but you guys did
it the most and the best and with the
least remorse and guilt about it and
within the entire earth had slaves for
like hundreds of thousands of years yeah
and it continued through capitalism so
if we want to stop it now we got to stop
it through capitalism that's the skin
that it's wearing right now
um tell us about the slave trade since
you know yeah i look i learned from
history i go to school i listen not like
you [ __ ] d average students
the [ __ ] do you know you're just trying
to [ __ ]
emotionally feel good you don't go to
school to learn you go to school to
[ __ ]
uh feel good about yourself
you don't know anything about learning
and the discipline required because
you're dumb hillbillies
um wealth of nations slavery is
inefficient through the lands of
capitals
yeah having free labor is inefficient
that's why we pay cows because it's so
efficient to
not have free labor
and i didn't do that by the way yeah but
you benefit from it
um slavery uh was what this country was
founded on and without the proper um
attitude towards it you're gonna do
versions of it
and that's what that's why our minimum
wage is so low because we're so used to
slavery it's like imagine if you went to
nazis and been like remember the
holocaust
i don't do it who cares it's not it was
such a long time ago that's not an
attitude of a healthy culture towards
the atrocities they committed
[ __ ]
that's so crazy
um
slavery stopped through capitalism you
think slavery we don't have slavery
anymore you don't think we have
just a slightly better version of it
that's applied to more people
um
i think that um
we try to get as close to slavery as
possible without revolutions happening
and we pay people as little as possible
and we have worse wealth inequality now
than we did in uh
the french revolution and you know who
stopped slavery not the people that were
proponents of capitalism
the people that were
humanitarians and you know emotional
liberal bleeding hearts stopped slavery
the people that wanted to to stop like
abraham lincoln
um but yeah i mean good job on stopping
slavery you know you stop doing
something evil pat yourself on the back
for that
real good job that was but yeah i mean
that was the beginning of capitalism and
i just think that it's just too much
uh justifying of horrible [ __ ]
and that's what it is for like the
immigrant stuff and they're like
immigrants are so horrible we need to
keep them out
and then we use like
um
you know
um
i don't really know what uh arguments
they use
for immigrants i need brick and i need
rock
both of them are provided here for me on
this beautiful spot
close to me
seven
this is nine if cows could provide value
outside their current use then it would
be efficient inefficient
cows could provide value outside their
current use
it would be inefficient to pay them
uh well yeah we we provide a lot of
value outside of our work and so we
should be subsidized by the government
to further our artistic endeavors
because that's how you get
um you know
cool [ __ ]
um i think i want to go here
i think i'll go here
up here or something
i'll go here
and i'll go here
oh [ __ ] i should have left that open
it's too long
this is too dicey
this is safer
six five
one two
and go this way
let's just
okay
i'm gonna go this way
okay
slaver is what all human civilizations
were founded on yes but you guys did one
of the worst versions of slavery called
chattel slavery and treated them
horribly
and you never
uh really fully recovered from that
after the civil war you were stubborn
and
insubordinate and you're like who cares
we didn't and then that's what your
culture is based on is justifying
slavery in the south like look out how
many like rebel flags and [ __ ] are
around
like all cultures did slavery but no one
defended it and was like it's fine we
don't have to recover we don't have to
fix it we just have to ignore it look
all these other people did it uh
what who are you talking to although
that wasn't as strong man i was going
i'm done if she pick your nose i need it
usually the way things work is you pay
for something then receive it yeah and
who who controls all the money who has
all the capital and all the products and
this
the stuff in the world is the people
that you probably are white dudes and
then you're like oh yeah we just have to
let money rule
uh money will be the decider of
everything so it's the people who has
all the money
free trade capitalism any centralized
government system well that's what they
said about feudalism feudalism was the
best system until capitalism came around
and
people who were all feudalists didn't
want capitalism to come around and
that's what you guys are defending an
old system that doesn't work and it's
destroying our planet
you just are comedian you demand your
rights that'd be great you know i don't
know if it would make sense in this um
context you did you guys did who did
uh you are part of something larger than
yourself
you are not just an individual but also
a lot of other people have uh
contributed to where you are now and you
are part of that larger thing and you
should get used to that feeling because
that's a good feeling instead of just
thinking about yourself the whole time
you're praying less i know it's also
more global than any other type of
slavery
i'm not american and all versions of
slavery were bad yes and your version of
slavery was bad that you're defending
right now the one that is most impactful
to our culture and society through
american culture is american slavery
and to be like oh other cultures did it
worse and to be like no capitalism isn't
based on slavery and genocide when that
was like what we did as a country to
become an economic superpower
and to have the land and resources
it's uh
it's relevant and it's a part of our
culture and we should um
work to excise it
and make sure that we have a beautiful
beautiful culture that is free of
gunk and
you know selfishness
uh what is it called uh he has 1500
years of brutal slavery i don't know if
you could call korean history slavery
um
i mean you could say america slavery
wage slavery why is it called the rebel
flag
hansbrough you living in your van in
austin is a better life than 80 percent
of the world yeah you know why it's
shitty is because you made it shitty you
invaded every country and staged coups
in guatemala and iran and then you're
like look we're the best country yeah
because you didn't let any other country
be awesome because you're insecure
i don't hold responsibility for slave
owners none of us do
yes you do you hold responsibility for
the country you're in uh if you enjoy
the benefits of the country you're in
you also have to deal with the
responsibilities of living in that
country it's not just positive if you
want to be a part
of the uh
the country you're in which you are you
should also take responsibility for the
negative parts of it which is include
slavery
and since you take the benefits of
living in this country you should also
take the responsibilities um do you ever
have political discussion with tony in
the game no because they disagree with
me
they uh i i just stay silent and let
them talk because i don't i don't think
anything i would have to say would be
helpful be sure to bring this up with
joe rogan at the next dinner
yeah yeah this is what i think and you
know i don't think joe would like it if
i changed what i think to match what he
thinks so
i'm going to be an honorable respectable
respectful man and uh hold on to my
beliefs your slavery as if anyone alive
today is responsible for it we're not
and it's really a stupid thing to say
well i don't keep saying you're slavery
you keep bringing it up
and being like i didn't do it i didn't
do it i didn't do it
and uh like i said if you want to take
the benefits of this country you also
have to take the negative sides of it
and uh part of the negative side of
slavery and our culture and our society
is just used to slavery
we're used to treating people like [ __ ]
we're used to people being less than and
nothing and that's a big part
of
our country
and
yeah i mean i'm ready to hold that
responsibility as an american
and you should too
it's not that hard
you just be like yeah we did slavery
that's horrible or we can be bad people
not other people are bad too
other people are horrible
new tech causes rampant class
stratification he decides what happens
to the people that get left behind
uh
the core idea of capitalism is a mutual
benefit for all parties involved
thinking or modern day capitalism
doesn't really make sense
linking or modern day capitalism with
what doesn't make sense the core idea of
capitalism is not mutual benefit for all
parties involved it's people with
capital getting everything and people
who don't have capital the workers the
80 90 of the population getting nothing
that is what capitalism means it's named
after the people who own capital
it's not going to be a very wealth uh
it's not going to be a very equal
society when your [ __ ] is needed for the
richest people who have the most power
um
i do live in this country and i take
responsibility for slavery and i feel
bad about it i just have to feel bad you
don't have to like [ __ ]
do anything besides feel bad and uh let
that be your guiding light to what you
should do like people don't want to feel
bad they'll do anything to avoid feeling
bad because they know if they start
then it's like a long road of a lot of
bad feelings that will happen
but i mean it's not all you should do
it's part of what you should do but
people don't even want to do that they
don't even want to feel bad but like i
refuse
i will
feel awesome all the time i refuse to
feel bad even for a minute
uh
i'm trolling a bit but i do hate your
beliefs
[Music]
yeah i know
it's not easy i'm not taking
responsibility for any of the american
government
yeah well don't what do you hold
responsibility for
everything
what do you mean
um in arguments i'm like yeah i'm from
america we had slaves our culture is
built on toxicity
uh what do you hold responsibility for
okay what does holding responsibility
mean feeling bad feel bad dude you need
to feel bad if you don't feel bad
nothing else is gonna change it's the
start of change is you feeling bad you
have to feel bad i know it's like your
worst thing you don't want to ever feel
bad
but uh you're gonna have to feel bad
it's a part of growth
and uh just because the thing larger
than you is bad doesn't mean that you're
a bad person
imagine simping for capitalism in a
youtube comment
i mean youtube is a very capitalist
organization once people start once an
organization has capital it's easier to
accrue more capital and the more capital
and then the end result of capitalism is
crony capitalism it's a monopoly there's
no such thing as
uh
there's no difference between crony
capitalism and capitalism it's the same
thing that's the end result of
capitalism there's no other way this
plays out if you start getting rich you
get richer and richer until the
government gets involved and busts up
monopolies which is what we do in this
country with very little backlash to it
because
uh that's fine you know that's not
communism that's the government doing
things but
um people hate that
people love that
only responsibility is although that
there have been historical injustices
and using the doctors and actions to
counteract those injustices i feel like
you can acknowledge slavery was a bad
thing but you don't have to live in
shame our country's history of slavery
doesn't define anyone today nor should
it
be something anyone carries
i mean there is historical
um baggage you know like as long as
black people are living in the ghetto in
poverty like you should be ashamed of
that you should be
you should feel bad about that that's a
horrible black mark on our country it's
not good at all
um
[Music]
yeah who knows
who knows what the [ __ ]
what's going on with stuff
um
i don't know what to do
i want to build
a goddamn city
okay
han's literally building consciousness
among all you people right now
acting on his responsibility
yeah you know i'm tanking this [ __ ]
stream making it boring as [ __ ] talking
about slavery you know that's what i'm
doing i'm i'm being boring for the cause
i mean i make good money and live a good
life i don't want to feel bad lamell
well if you have a good money and good
life you can feel bad you can afford to
feel bad more than anyone or we acting
like acquiring capital is some
impossible task because the people who
have capital make sure that you can't
get capital
like people who are already ahead they
don't want you to get ahead so they oh
[ __ ]
so they uh prevent you from getting
ahead
i mean it'd be nice if they didn't
if we lived in a world where everything
was beautiful and people just let you do
the best
but unfortunately that's not the world
we live in and uh people will [ __ ] with
you
oh yeah
i'm holding
wherever i just know white
people and capitalism yeah in the long
run we'll all benefit from the end of
inequality because you know nobody likes
walking to their car
feeling like someone's going to mug them
and if black people are not in poverty
they will stop doing that [ __ ]
but you know mexican people did too and
white people did too according to
government gets involved and manipulates
the government who controls the
government that's
getting involved in manipulating
is it corporations
so you mean corporations where they get
more power and more capital they are
able to influence the government and
they have no reason not to they're
actually incentivized by their
shareholders
to influence the government to get more
money and if you don't then you're a bad
company and you'll get fired you know
bad ceo so there's no way this ends in
capitalism besides cronin capitalism
because it is their job and their duty
to
you know influence the government
if they can and if they don't then
they're not gonna they're not doing
their job
uh 7 9
9 12.
i feel bad for them but i don't feel bad
for that your government is your trust
daddy government your problem is you
trust daddy government
yeah i mean i trust the concept of
government which is rule by the people
because i trust people i think people
are beautiful and that's all we have if
we don't trust people is we might as
well not do it because everyone's a
person eventually you're gonna have to
trust people you might trust a few small
group of people you might trust
you know different versions of people
but at the end of the day it's just
people so why don't why don't we just
make people awesome
and we'd make people awesome by not
letting them grow up in poverty
and be sad and poor and [ __ ]
and you know the government should be
controlled by the people it's not the
best way to do things you know sometimes
the people make stupid decisions like
you know
they protest the wrong thing or whatever
but
you know at least
that's the people you know at least
uh overall i think it's a more
successful uh thing to do than just
letting a small group of people control
it for their own interests
um but uh
if you love your life
with that mentality that everyone is
against you you're right you will not
grow or become successful but it's
changing your mindset and telling
yourself that you aren't a statistic
well i don't think that just being part
of something larger than yourself
has to mean that you're telling yourself
that you're part of assisted statistic i
think being a part of something larger
than yourself
is has some sad parts to it but also
some awesome parts to it that a lot of
americans are afraid of because i mean i
think i'm asian so i'm more uh
you know open to um
uh feeling like being a part of
something larger than myself is a good
thing you know when there's bad parts of
it that i think asians
should watch out for
[Music]
um but uh
yeah i mean
so if you take the money
away from where there is no urge for
power in the power structure seriously
um i mean there's always an urge for
power but i think that uh capitalism
accentuates and exaggerates it and we're
like look at how crazy people are with
power yeah because you live in a system
where power is chosen and emphasized
um
ubi step one point out a problem with
human society step two blame capitalism
well we live in a capitalist society so
any problems that exist are probably
stemming from capitalism
if we lived in another society i'd
criticize that too
i think that capitalists have a very
hard time taking criticism
they uh they want to act like
everything's perfect but we all know
it's not this is you got everything you
wanted this is your system at work
during the 80s and 90s reagan did
whatever the [ __ ] you want wanted and
look what we got in sync and [ __ ]
[ __ ] music
um
[Music]
but uh yeah i mean i think uh
i think like uh you know
just pointing out that the world is
shitty doesn't mean i'm uh i feel bad or
shitty or you know like the world is
shitty yeah
um
and uh i'm fine with that it doesn't
mean i have to feel bad all the time or
i i feel bad sometimes when i think
about it but you know there's a lot of
individual experiences that save me from
just feeling bad all the time
[Music]
i think that
i think that
um
you're american get over it being larger
than yourself is a fantasy it's the
problem with everyone not gen x i think
the problem is that we don't think we're
large that we don't
we aren't a part of something larger
than ourselves because if we were we'd
be more aware of [ __ ] and be
you know
more with it but i think like we're all
fat uh narcissists and we're only
thinking about ourselves and i think
that's the problem with jen's ex not
that we are more in tune with our higher
consciousness that would be awesome if
it was
there's a corrupt deal in
government you don't
you don't blame the con artist you blame
the central authority
that you need to trust
if your dad cheats with a random moment
you don't blame the random woman you
blame your dad same concept
but who controls your dad who controls
the central government the corporations
who have all the money and by lobbyists
and pave politicians
they control the government so
what other system
[Music]
what other way of what other who else is
controlling the government if it's not
corporations and the rich
uh you know like
i think that um
i think that if you want to uh
fix your [ __ ] you should uh
get rid of the money in it because like
once companies start getting more money
then
they want to get more money and so they
influence the government if they have
the money they're the ones influencing
the government so anything that's wrong
with the capitalist government is
probably the rich
ceos and companies behind that
capitalist government not the idea of
government
and not the idea of voting and not the
idea of people controlling the
government
i
like to hear your ideal world because
your
ideas just don't sound like they work in
a world without with human nature humans
are flawed and bad but we all make
mistakes how would your society
um i think that you're just used to this
world so you can't really imagine
anything else and you're like anything
else is just like
um
a foreign concept and it's like oh it's
it's
it's an ideal uh utopia it wouldn't work
because i haven't seen it before
and uh i don't think you're trying that
hard to imagine my ideal world or any
ideal world i think you're just trying
to get good at whatever this world is
are you going to pick your nose anita
for money or yes or no like many people
you blame capitalism when you should
really be blaming government
interference with capitalism but who
controls the government who controls the
government uh with all their money you
know who is in charge of the government
who's paying those people
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
speeches after they retire
it's not the people it's random ass
companies
so maybe if i want to fix the problem i
shouldn't just blame the concept of
government but i should fix the people
who are paying that government
and uh are controlling that government
through money
i mean
what what do you want to blame
capitalism for surely there's something
capitalism could improve upon like you
want to just let it go of anything
there's nothing you want to blame
capitalism for like it's not there's
nothing to fix about it you just want to
be like it's uh
it's uh you know
it's perfect
we just got to keep going we know it's
not perfect because it feels horrible uh
planet's dying you know people are in
wealth inequality there's like
uh people in the ghetto and you know
the cops are predatory and you know be
people
um but the good thing about nowadays is
that i can just pretend i'm like
bla back the blue and they'll be like
they won't hit me as hard because
they're like oh he supports us so
there's like they do love some people
in a different way which is nice
and he's going to act as governments of
their own when they grow large enough
they will keep him in check if not the
government
um
yeah let's get rid of government and
just let the corporations rule
what do they need to be in check of how
you address capital allocations in
government i think american culture will
always make governments better handling
our taxes
uh how do you address a capital
allocation government i think that the
best way to address capital allocation
in government is
with a handy little trick i like to call
pooping
capital allocation um you know
nationalize it vote on it let the people
decide
um
etc etc free world big government pick
one i think you have more freedom
in scandinavian countries and countries
with public transit
and uh health care than a world where
corporations and people with the most
money rule
you're trying to blame the pretty woman
for corrupting your dead you should be
blaming the dad figure
slash government how did the how is the
government the woman in this example
um i think that uh
my dad if he's a corporation is hungry
for power and wants more power
and then he uses
the government to get what he wants
i am not going with you on this uh
analogy
so the government is thinking with a
hard pekka
stopping what's stopping a multinational
company
from being authoritarian
humans bad capital good
yeah i mean do you love people or
do you love money
which one do you think should have a
future in our society do you think we
should be a society ruled by money
just money running around wild packs of
money i'm open to the idea of new
concepts i just want to hear your
opinion on how the world works it just
seems like you're pointing out flaws and
just
saying rally against the issues
well i think nationalizing things helps
um
i think that uh
like something should be nationalized
like healthcare like the police
department
um
[Music]
rick and sheep prick in shape
and uh
i'm gonna get brick
now i just oh i just got more brick
well now i just need more brick
um i mean i the ideal world i would say
is sort of like japan or scandinavia
you know just somewhere where the
government just does its job and
people are allowed to be whatever they
are
just you
uh the pretty woman does not control the
cheating father i like counting them but
i think it might be extremely beneficial
if society replaced welfare with the ubi
that never scales back as people make
more money and come on their own cause
only 1.5 times
so that yang yeah i think people should
be provided like a little basic
little thing so that you know we don't
have to starve to death and [ __ ]
and then uh once people have that
security they can take a deep breath and
decide what they want to do with their
life and stop acting like rabid animals
stop blessing blame from the government
employer cheating the people to the
wolves in the world trying to cheat from
everyone
i mean someone's cheating people is it
the person who got into the government
job
where they get paid like 50k and have
like a pension and a health care system
or is it the cheating people who are
predatory and selfish is it the wall
street brokers and the people who own
businesses who
only care about money who do you think
is a worse problem if you're trying to
get rid of selfishness
and cheating in the world which is the
problem right now is that people are
accruing and greedy
oh god
i did so bad how did this guy do so good
jesus
is it a nice thing
did he have a lot of aids
a lot of sixes and fives
let's see five and nine should be rolled
the same time it was rolled once this
was rolled seven times so whoever got
nine got really [ __ ] i had nine it
only got rolled once
dude imagine if i got rolled that many
times but maybe it's random maybe it's
the distribution
tens and elevens threes and twos did
really well tens
elevens
threes
and twos
oh these twos did well two's got more
than nines
you got a lot of eight
four
six
five eleven he had an 11 right there
and another one
oh god am i ever gonna win
if government is cheating us they are
the ones who need to be replaced well if
we get a new government is the
corporation not gonna bribe this one
they're just gonna be like you're gonna
you're fine
you ain't gonna take my capital though
good luck
well what if it's for the benefit of the
earth you're just gonna selfishly hold
on to that even though it's hurting the
planet yeah let's get that focused on
i'm done you gonna skip that
okay that knowledge again i don't want
to read that analogy he does government
so much he ignores its evil actions well
you have corporations so much who
controls the government every time the
government does something bad it's at
the behest of a corporation
politics religion symbol or ridiculous
conversations cliche
yes hans what about situation limited
resources capital allocation by
democrats democracies will be just
deprived minorities nothing's perfect
well you know we already have a system
that deprives minorities so if you are
looking for a system that doesn't
deprive minority how about don't settle
for the system that gives rich people
all their money and it's named after
people who own capital and have all the
most money
how's it going
the bigger the government the bigger the
vector for corruption how about
corporations the bigger the corporation
the bigger the vector for
corruption
maybe
nine ten eleven
i like this spot
five ten eleven
the spot's more diverse
um
i think the spot will be gone
be gone
10 11 12 this is actually 12.
i like that spot a lot
the safest bet is to point it away from
everything but if you want to go for the
riskier maneuver then this is a good
thing to do
um
do i really want this
brick port
or do i want this three to one port
that's safer let's go for the safe bet
if you're not the first your last place
you'd have to collect it from people
okay also give you a thumbs up anyways
thumbs up everyone thanks kevin bergman
i appreciate it i actually had a unique
take on corporate interference politics
it may or may not be a good idea but he
wanted to attach a dollar value to a
vote that would drown out corporate
money by volume
yeah maybe
that sounds
interesting it sounds fanciful and
you know
it seems like a lot of work to it seems
like a
like first we have to have that desire
to not have corporations rule anything
and then that'll work but like once we
get that yeah i'm sure
but the bigger issue is like do you
really want to do it and then if that
happens i don't think there'll be a need
for that
for these little tricks
if we get the men to dream of the ocean
then we don't need to
you know worry about how many nails to
buy i'm not saying government won't be
corrupted i'm not saying it should be
small so that it does not get corrupted
it doesn't enslave humanity
i like as you do as
one of the top young rising comedians of
the world please
people really uh don't want to hear me
talk politics anymore it's about the
cones cones and the bones how's your
feelings was better and people would
actually do art how would the comedy
scene be different
uh if we all had
food and shelter
then the police the
comedy scene would be beautiful it'd be
thriving there'd be people just out
there just farting about
just having a good old time just
you know relaxed ah
everyone's relaxed finally we can relax
and then we can just talk like hey look
it's this guy whoa
look at this guy doing whatever he does
uh government equals to govern but the
corporations
govern through money
as a government because less power
something will fill a vacuum yeah
money
um take away government what is left for
corpse to control exactly
people
labor
property
um
so one of the cool things that i get to
do as one of the top young writers and
comedians in the world is i get to
meet some of the most famous people from
some of the most accomplished great
comedians of our time
you know shane gillis greg fitzsimmons
tom segura ron white i've also i've
shared a green room with each one of
these people i've shaved the same air i
could have given them covet if i could
if i had it
um and i didn't
but i could have and that kind of
intimacy that's how you show
uh your
loyal your you know your your trust of
someone as if you're even willing to get
covered from them
uh you know mark normand and all that
so that's pretty cool mark normand is
exactly like how he is on stage he's
always riffing he's funny
he's listens to everyone even me
he even listens to me shane gillis is so
nice he's like an older brother he's
like ah
come on hans you [ __ ] idiot
uh but yeah i mean he's nice even though
he called me a [ __ ] no just kidding he
didn't call me a [ __ ]
no um i didn't kiss any of them
you know female comedians such as
and
i've met many female comedians
i met bonnie mcfarland mcfarland
she was uh
shooting 20 somethings
and she was in the green room at the
creek
so what do you guys think about uh
tech bros in texas aka texas's
um
i'm using my girlfriend as motivation to
get things done
so
i need sheep and i need rock
um unfortunately
they're only together right here which
isn't a very valuable spot
this might be a doable thing if i just
want to forego rock completely
i can't build on this six which is
unfortunate because then i could have
gotten this
oh it's kind of far away
um i could get this sheet port
get wood
i wouldn't have sheep though so what's
the point of a sheet port when you don't
have sheep
what's funny did she touch your camera
through the fence while you're refusing
to feathering it
no she's like he would show me and
unlock if he weren't if you were in high
school yeah i know he seems like that
and then he's like that and then he's
like sort of not
so that's cool
i think the allergies here are getting
to me and texas the allergies here are
really bad and i think it's because they
don't know how to plant trees correctly
because they planted trees like they
build their highways
i think the same person was in charge
because ever since i saw this [ __ ]
vox
or vice whatever [ __ ] about how
trees were
planted as all male trees because like
the female trees were like really uh
fruity and smelled bad so it was all
male under the male trees were like wait
a minute there's no [ __ ] here and
they just started pumping up pollen
and we were we had more pollen than is
natural
and uh we just don't know how to control
our environment correctly because we
murdered the native americans and that
part of us
that cares about that kind of [ __ ]
what am i gonna do i can't get sheep
except in these shitty little locations
man
i really wish i had a better location to
get shape at
i could get this
and i'll get rock there
that might be nice
that's the only place i can rock except
for here
that's only five dots this is
ten dots
uh
i'm gonna do it
[ __ ] it
i'm gonna do it
let's see who do i wanna take from
i wanna take
i'm gonna put it here and [ __ ] over a
lot of people with rock
or i can put it here if i i don't really
need their [ __ ] brick 10 this is 12.
so i'm going to take this guy
and i'm going to take from red
i got a brick
brick-a-bucky eight dots here
five dots here
i'm gonna go for this one dog
that's got two
it would brick and i don't have a sheep
maybe i should have put it on the six
it's only ten dots this will get rid of
twelve dots for me
uh
this is having a fun impression
yo guys i'm theo vaughn here
yo dog it was so big man
i can't believe how big it was dude
you wouldn't even believe it it was that
big man i'm not even joking and then you
talked to [ __ ]
hans would you like more a lot or austin
austin all the way [ __ ]
i don't want to build my career
on
my
how good i am at
serving
the existing power structure i don't
want to be like oh look i'm very good at
respecting the things that already exist
i want to be good at [ __ ] making my
art and only concentrating on that
instead of just you know changing who i
am to be beneficial to the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
from the [ __ ]
so you know i don't like the entrenched
power structure there i like that here
it's new and fresh and beautiful
i like that
here it's freedom
we get freedom to make our own [ __ ]
instead of just going up to someone and
sucking their dick there's very little
dick sucking here i mean i probably do
the most dick sucking in austin and
i'm not even good at it so if they think
that i'm a good dick sucker here you can
see that that's not a thing that they
reward
dick sucking is not a very
uh highly rewarded thing in austin
culture
and that's what's beautiful but to be
not a dick sucker cause i don't suck
dick like in l.a
i'm free and i do whatever the [ __ ] i
want because i live in austin and i'm a
good person and i'm [ __ ] awesome
because i don't need other people's
approval to feel good about
myself um
how dare you defame theo
san antonio i'm making breakfast tacos
every day
your homes come to san antonio homes i'm
making breakfast tacos every day
i know someone recorded that so hanzo
seoul valen impression can live on
forever
uh i'm sure you've been asked this
before but do you do most of your
writing on or off stage if you do both
do you enjoy doing one over the other
i do my joke writing on stage and then i
also do my joke writing off stage in an
on stage off stage combination
it's a one-two punch that i like to call
the hans method
and it implies
that i'm
doing both well the thing is like
there's only so much time i'm on stage
so if i'm not on stage
then um
and um
and the writing and server
i did not mean to do that
oopsies
well hopefully a 7 gets rolled
then i can put this thing to use oh yeah
baby
is this just on youtube or twitch also
this is just on youtube dude i wish i
could do both but it's it's all [ __ ]
when i try to do both i'm just going to
do this do you think son hong min has a
chance to has to leave taunton to reach
his football
whatever
his football uh
hong son min i think
son can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants
that's what i think i'm a firm believer
that
um
okay
i got another [ __ ] wood
what am i gonna do with that
i need a wheat too
oh my god this is taking too much work i
already have six points
i'll just build one of these
[ __ ]
okay hillary's jokes when he has a
private judge now i mean look at me do
you think i don't write jokes i look
like a writer i need to write um i think
it's good to do both i mean
some people don't like writing off stage
but then i hope that they're writing
in their heads or like thinking of
things constantly because if you have
that ability to think of things before
a show you have this much time to think
of things and the shows this long
then you're gonna
have a lot more jokes because you're
thinking of jokes this whole time so i
would love to use this whole joke
writing time to write jokes instead of
just this little time
because there's always going to be more
time to
uh
be off stage than on stage so if you can
write jokes off stage then it's better
because you can write more jokes every
texas has a common culture back in the
age without he's like bill huck's fault
for
the outlet
you should host a podcast where a bunch
of comedians play dnd
do you think someone
bikes
is this just on youtube
okay well here's the thing is um
i uh
i think it's funny that a lot of people
don't uh
don't try to [ __ ] with me too much
so i only have two points
oh my god this sucks
[Music]
i loved love ralphie may
that's the good thing about comedy is
that even if you die it lives on through
recorded work so it doesn't ever feel
like you're dead because you can always
watch them
and get the same essence of their life
their life has captured their unique
fingerprint of wherever they were
is recorded
it's interesting because i'm not getting
anything else but wooden brick
and
i would love
some goddamn wheat
because i have so much of it
and i'm not getting a sausage
well there i go
i need some sheep
who needs
literally anything so i can provide it
for you
sheepies
no one wants a little shapey
i'll put it here so it's easier to make
sheep next time because that was [ __ ]
difficult
i'll lead you from massachusetts to
austin in a
rv with my eight-year-old grandma
just so i could see kill tony in person
in october but i had other reasons to be
in texas but kill tony what's the
priority
that's sweet
um
two juices walk into a bar they hurt
their heads
take that to the stage
you take that to the stage what's on the
far right comedian's lifespan no luck
and so good now
so a funny thing is that a lot of people
are unsure about
asset-backed mortgages
and i just have to say that we should
take a look at it and figure it out
and have a good time
overall
so here's a question for the chat
what do you guys think of the
jews
sound off in the comments
let's hear it
um
joe
flabbergast
says the jews
i can't believe that they're still
around
what are they even doing nowadays
that's a great question joe flabbergast
the jews are
alive and kicking
they are actually kicking too hard and
they're trying to kick the palestinians
out of
their native homeland
you know they were there before the jews
all came in and now they're getting
kicked out so it's not kind of sad um
besides that the jews
are
enjoying each other's companies having a
good time eating pizza
doing all the things that normal jews do
that make them so jewish
okay
whatever you guys hate me
that's fine
two brick i need a brick
anyone want to give me a break
i really need a brick
oh my god i can't believe it's blocked
i hate that so much
luckily
i got my wheat pork coming in
so
hebrews he jews hello did you wake up
and decide to get cancelled we do we
choose to care about
like
oh
i'm gonna give up all of it
well i want to build a settlement that's
my mission
oh no i hate that i heard that so much
well at least the brick opened up
hopefully i'll get
two more break
oh
that sucks so hard
that sucks so hard man
come on orange i'm waiting for you
to eat
a brick
no thank you hans how much to call tony
right now
i don't i don't think it's worth it
rick finally i got my brick i'm so happy
mom
i can't believe it huh that much um
so what i think about jesus is that it's
nice if he's helpful to people but i
think he's just been hijacked by the
powers that be to do whatever the [ __ ]
they are doing
and if you believe in him it's like just
like an open back door that you give to
the government and corporations
and it's nice
it's like wow you got through life with
this huge vulnerability in your
operating system that's impressive
um
and also people are like oh good he's
easily hackable i can relax around him
because he's not gonna go crazy and [ __ ]
but i think overall you probably
probably don't want to have a lot of
that [ __ ] in your head
you probably want to be free
like me
because i'm proud to be an american
imagine that i said you can't make free
trades well
i hear jews have to convert and rename
themselves patty o'malley patty o'malley
that's me patio
i graduated as an engineer
but prior to santa were you ever
interested in pursuing another
mediums
i would love to pursue the artistic
medium of
music if it wasn't so corrupted by
beauty
can't i be an ugly
musician
like why does everyone have to be so
[ __ ] hot all the time
jesus
oh yeah
great job
i guess we're all tied now
on a night i get so much
i really love it
oh look ma a four
i really like it when i roll a four
oh my i love you mom
i really like it when i can roll a four
uh brick
nose thank you
creep
more like an artistic low am i right
um i think that uh
what i would love to do artistically is
painting i think would be nice it just
seems a little corrupt in my opinion
um
i think uh
stand-up comedy was great because it's
so
it's like so shitty that no one would
want to take it over or it's like so
uncorruptable because it's all
individuals and it's like so um
i don't know comedy is like
so
uh
like if you're if you're
there's no question about it it's like
either you're good or you're not like
either you can talk to the society that
exists as it is now or you can't
and the results are tangible and you can
feel it
and uh
yeah i mean
it's
it's just fine and dandy
oh a seven
lord have mercy
he rolled the seven
hallelujah
um
and like with art with stuff like uh
you know
uh painting
it's like it's not really
it's not really uh easy to be like oh
who's uh who's actually good at this
is he going to steal from me
um
yeah and with music it's like people
want to feel it in their genitals more
so unless you're sexy as well then it's
not as easy to do it's not as easy to
pull off
i forgot i'm blue
um free speech is someone you don't like
saying something you don't agree with me
you don't agree with
yeah i mean it's awesome to have that
but we should also be in a place where
people are saying awesome things instead
of horrible things
like our ideals shouldn't just be
free random horrible thoughts and ideas
running around but
we should also try to maintain the
quality of our thoughts to be high
and uh
you know the mind is a terrible thing to
lose
it affects people it makes a visceral
effect
it has a visceral effect
scratch let me off the sentence shaub is
getting into rap and selling wigs ghee
uh whiskey is good um
i think it's fine if you want to do it
um
oh god
i need a shape i'm never getting a sheep
i'm gonna live a sheepless life
sheepless in seattle
seven
all right will you be my savior
will you save me orange
um so what do you guys think about the
ukraine christ oh he stole from me
he stole from me why would he steal from
me
doesn't even make any sense
let's go
wait wasn't work
i see
black
sure
i still need that wheat though
i need a wheat or a brick
watching this this morning okay
um i need wait
oh my god all right just trying to [ __ ]
me
i don't need it that bad
i think ukraine could be solved
we just need to figure out our
differences
we just need to be better better people
um
so what do you guys think about
what do you guys think about the whole
do you think that we should walk we live
in
i think maybe we should live in walkable
communities
um
let me see
there's a video out
uh
thanks to
all right
thank you guys bye
i'm gonna go
oh yeah i gotta wait
all right see you guys